on a heurté un truc qu'on a renversé
quelqu'un sur quoi pourquoi tu en étais
la route des yeux respect calme une
seconde en se concentrant sur la con
album toi on a tous bu de l'alcool on
est tous ptg dire dans la poche evans
risque au moins 15 ans de prison pour ce
à quoi
nous emmène loin d'ici je vais pas
prendre les filles je vais voir ce que
c'était
qui s'usaient
et puis tous ces choristes drake
tentacules de pieux je sais pas très
bien bon je crois que cette évidence qui
s'est passé les gars c'est pas la peine
d'être neurochirurgien pour comprendre
ça evans accidentellement évidemment à
l'heure tu es un cageot tombé du
chargement d'un camion qui transportait
en effet des pieuvres très fraîchement
pêchés vers un restaurant de sushis des
environs d'accord au pire si on ou non
evans a buté un japonais qui mangeait
une pioche entre ça va pas je n'ai pas
buté qui que ce soit
c'est de la pieuvre fraîchement pêchés
attendez j'ai déjà vu ce truc visqueux y
avait ce truc là tout autour du cadavre
d'antonio avait récemment